[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right what is your name
I'm in there I'm Amanda yeah and would
you grow up in LA
tell me what your family you grew up
with both your pal I'm cool and they
take me I think about anyone my dad
turned out to be my yes sir so his wife
welcome um so now I'm down I live
downtown that way nice house with you
and I look like a you do click yeah
where do you stay here and you know I
just watch the streets all night yeah
yeah and I'm alone mm-hmm oh did I were
you talk to you yeah you sure I haven't
talked to you I think I have no so so
what do you say what now I say I think
I'm with my father basil in like a turn
out to be a molester so I just walk this
read and like process hearing and
smoking downtown LA yeah you look very
different I think it's I think I spoke
to you before um it
have you finished school have you eaten
and they are like I said his name
ELP a special program I got that after
two years you jumped out from where
honey College see us two years of
college
hmm and do you have any contact with
your family at all your mom got killed
in a fire um she wasn't in my life
anyway then I lied to a lot of people I
was telling them excuse in my life you
know this is he normal
so well my mom Carol recently
a fire hole do you know it's me three
Catherine and you got a black eye yeah
but you get the right guy on my date
I'm asking they're gonna get for my
crack and you just took off on me I'm
I'm a clone so people control me so they
use technology you know Orthodox them to
beat me up because they get frustrated
cuz I'm comfortable when I get
comfortable
do you have any family at all yes uncle
yeah my dad but he's turned out to be
unless they're just your dad yeah no I
must impress you have no support yeah
and the only money you get is from the
guys on the street right or ask for
dollars and change from the liquor store
oh yeah well I do want to say um it's
kind of random
I'm usually interviewing me before but I
want to tell my country thank you so
much for you know seeing the whole
downtown scene
I'm sorry for not cleaning myself up
they were really trying but you know
Stan I'm gonna be doing crack like a
year and a half only a year and a half
yeah you were in college just a few
years ago yeah like crack of investing
for me I really miss my heart and it's
like you know yeah van it's my
everything crack is your everything yeah
people lean on drugs
yeah and who are you hanging with now
the gentleman that is I was obtained by
myself or my the other has cracked but
oh so he has practically yeah I just um
I started crying I take crack
and sometimes the guys beat you up yeah
maybe Mia who beat you up
it's Mexican um I'm a calm scrappy and
control so the people that control me
get frustrated when I'm comfortable so
they ought to like him with technology
where they control people to beat me up
so it was hard
Amanda there's there's a couple like
mental health places there right in the
neighborhood here would you mind maybe
going over there yeah I've been to this
home a couple of times now you're
frustrating there's no drugs
what do you do I see a frustrated
there's no drugs did you leave no saying
that two or three days I stay stays
thank you and then you leave yeah I'm a
clone so I'm also hurting someone else
cuz they use animals she was you know
that's part of this technology I used to
clone you so I'm hurting someone else so
I I die today or tomorrow
so you really got to stay productive in
this country make sure you have a job
make sure that everything's together you
have a purpose you're always reaching
for something because they'll they'll
kill you on your interns here I just I
have a story line in my head you know
Stan cuz um my cuz we put a storyline in
my head so in that storyline they say
that America you know Stan everybody
gets murdered skull this live life to
the fullest I don't know how true that
is but I know I'm a clone so yeah that's
what's up
okay so if I if I if I want to walk you
over to one of the mental health
facilities here no I'm gonna get killed
today or tomorrow so I want to be out
and enjoy I'm enjoying you know crack
and just being out so that's it
but I'm now I gots gonna make a second
video with you so I can show my country
thank you so much and
the person that writes my thoughts might
tell you I have someone grateful times
but you know here I'm really thankful
I'm so sorry about everybody dying I
didn't know but when I heard about them
you know it's you know everybody you
know scanner you can I can't change me
thank you
you